I'm not a nice person when you try and
come on to me while I'm working out
after I tell you I'm 17. I go to your
[__] minds
[Music]
[Applause]
hey you a 24 year old man yeah like 17
is legal that is crazy
that is wild he said wow nah nah listen
I almost open maybe this is one of those
women who being crazy that's not this
that's wild that's wild no no no no no
no we're not doing that no no no bro
yeah listen you're crazy skip go go
straight to jail you do not collect 200.
nice person when you try and come on to
me while I'm working out after I tell
you I'm 17. I love your [__] line and
then you have the audition and tell me
get out of the gym that I have a right
to use 17 is legal no you said it louder
stop repeating people in the back that
didn't understand the only on
let me say something okay maybe some of
y'all
maybe some of y'all can't hear me
okay
let me say something oh my baby y'all
see me oh my day just cause it's legal
don't mean it's a good idea I could
drive my car with my feet don't make it
a good [__] idea I don't remember who
said that I think it was Chris Rock yes
step daughter don't make it a good idea
it's hot but it's not a good idea what's
up with your stepdaughter I don't know I
get your head out of your son don't
speak to me though listen listen
though hell no I need to keep pausing it
because
I wanna believe this video is fake
because this is so audacious dude you
gotta show this guy's face you not only
interrupted her workout after she said
no she tell you she's 17 which already
has a 24 year old man keep it [__]
moving and now you arguing her and then
you trying to use the Elder card to get
her to respond
send them home you 24. stupid yeah what
Elder you know you wallet you you barely
put on your adult diapers you've been
paid tax for what two three years get
the [__] Elder
Elder
who says that
now everything about this dude is off
yeah that's off respect your elders at
24 that's how you talk to a woman you've
never met she's talking about she
doesn't respect you did you respect her
space what she wanted
hey yo you're not that old but now I
have to respect you I just said let's go
out normally like normal I don't want to
go out with you especially after you
tell me to get the [__] out of a gym
that I have a right to use you told me
because you told me you won't don't
approach me who are you to tell me that
listen guys you can cry about how dating
is unfair you can say that's facts okay
if a girl says no keep it [__] moving
we don't want to hear all your excuses
all this other [__] get the [__] out of
there
and she tell you she's 17 and you still
arguing you a new fool
I hope your name get publicized
everywhere and everybody knows
[__] trash come on to me and feeling
you have a right to come on to me this
is useless go home go home go home no
home that's another dude
is it no it's the same guy go ahead it's
the same guy go home go home
go home watching [__] Taco get your
ass kicked out
get the [__] out of here you are right
there's another guy
it is another guy telling him to go home
because go home you understand go home
tell your daddy [__] you want to
tell get the [__] out of here I don't
[__] bro listen I'm done with you
[__] like bro I'm not gonna talk to
any of you yeah you're right because you
because you you give me trouble you give
me trouble okay this is all you do
you're not you're good for nothing get
out of here
I don't care
[Music]
hey [__] what's up like it was too
voicy we got aggressive with her that's
why I thought it was the second guy that
oh that's why I thought it was the
second time
yo it's been a long time since I've seen
something this audacious from somebody
what is there to say Hey listen lady you
missed out you missed out on years of
probably physical and verbal abuse you
probably missed out on somebody
gaslighting you and mistreating you
cause I mean if he treating you like
this before y'all even been on a date
imagine what it like being in a
relationship with it so I feel terrible
that you don't get to experience that a
lot of people don't want to acknowledge
that this is a reality for a lot of
women and they go through this stuff
there's definitely some of the women who
exaggerate and there's some of the women
who really go through it and you're
seeing it recorded like this in real
time I because all I had to go off was
voices If I Didn't Know Better I thought
it was two dudes about to scrap with how
this dude's voice changed and how he was
talking
and that's how he was talking to her
because she said no she wasn't
interested in that she's too young and
that you need to leave me alone it
sounds like there's nobody else in the
gym this sounds like it's a building gym
okay judging by the size of it
um and how quickly she was right at the
door I could be wrong but it looks like
that because no one else intervened and
I find it hard to believe if you in a
gym and you hear an argument like that
there's no way nobody intervening with
voices getting that loud yeah there's no
but nobody was in the gym that's a lot
that looked like a condo gym yes that's
what I'm trying to say so but the reason
why I'm bringing that up is that this
dude got that aggressive with her when
they were alone but that looks like she
made it out safely so unfortunately we
don't have more updates and more
information because I think it would
give more context to do it and I feel
like this dude should be blasted out
everywhere but maybe she didn't want to
for her own safety uh because he didn't
seem like he was too well up in the head
listen grow man [__] if a girl tell you
she anywhere near the illegal age keep
it [__] moving unless you're 19 20
even if you are if she tells you she
reject you that way
keep it [__] moving
to the left to the left even though I'm
pointing right it don't matter just move
Leaf go home go somewhere just don't be
there I don't get it due to holler at
teenage girls while they're grown ass
men they 30s you disgusted and I hope
you know whatever police Gotta Catch You
Gotta Catch You
but a girl tells you her age and you
said arguing with a teenager couldn't be
me
your thoughts some of you guys need to
really learn how to say no and I ought
to take a note
it's not the end of the world
there's gonna be other nodes that's one
two
I'm not saying it was better back then
but back then I personally would have
never
because you don't know if that girl has
big brothers
because if you would holler at my 17
year old sister
as a 24 year old man I would have
gathered the troops
and we would have come back to that gym
and set you up yep
and I'm talking real talk
and I know I am not the only one
I will call Cousins Brothers third
cousins
uncle's my mama and them
mm-hmm
and we getting you
that is crazy
fast for once
and for you my girl
I really hope you file a report like you
and you show that clip
to that guy
it went viral yes it went everyone saw
it including the people who know the
people who know him absolutely my you
know what's also real sometimes the
people originally take it down why
because they family act like you and so
they don't want some bad absolutely
because you don't want your back your
daddy your brother because your family
you know what they got down south oh
click click pow Poway escalation oh yeah
it ain't no no it's not a beating we we
I know
[Music]
I know some I know some families
you would have do that to one of the
family members it's a kidnapping
it's it's done can we just scroll it
back let's roll it back she says she's
17 and the man said he's legal that's
legal why do you know that
why was that such a quick reply
the fact that he knows that doesn't
surprise me but that's your go-to answer
and that's what I'm 17. that's a bit
[__] up that's a bit wow
I know what it's legal and what is not
the fact that I uh like hold up like a
girl tells you as a man
or girl
that age not a woman
a girl that is tells you I'm 17. what
are you doing
yo there's two layers
she looking at you when she's saying nah
dog and you double down there's two
layers to this age of consent is not
always clear-cut sometimes it's a
three-year difference sometimes it's
about a certain limit it just cuts off
knowing it is it weird in the vacuum no
having it instantaneously ready to go as
a reply that's [__] weird that's why
my boy
eventually something is going to happen
to you
I don't even need to wish it upon you
but if that's how you act out there
with girls
my boy
something is gonna happen to you
and when that happens
to me it's just something to happen
quick announcement we got the Reddit and
the Discord up so be sure to check the
descriptions of the link below for that
we also got our little video editing
contest if you want a full-time job
working for apple and preach you doing
our shorts or Tick Tock you can apply
easily by just making a video edit of us
on Tick Tock you edit it your way and
make the hashtag below Abba and preach
video context that's Abba and preach
video contest and then put it up there
we can put unlimited entries we want to
see how well you know the algorithm how
well you can make content that people
want to watch while also representing us
and if this possible we'll give you a
fully remote job paid doing work for
Avon preach so we want to see